okay
[Music]
[Applause]
why didn't you apologize to chris in
your acceptance speech
um
i was fogged out by that point
it's it's it's it's all fuzzy i've
reached out to
chris um
and the mesh the message that came back
is that
uh he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
um
so i will i will say to you
chris
i
apologize
to you
my behavior
was
unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk
um
i i want to apologize to
chris's mother i saw an interview that
chris's mother did
and
you know that was one of the things
about that moment i just didn't realize
and you know i wasn't thinking but how
many people got hurt in that moment
so i want to apologize to chris's mother
i want to apologize to uh chris's family
uh specifically tony rock you know we
had a great relationship
you know tony rock was my man um
and uh this is this is probably
irreparable
um
i spent the last
three months
um replaying
and
understanding the nuances and and the
complexities
of what happened
in in that moment
um
and
i'm not gonna try to unpack all of that
right now but i can say to
all of you there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment
there's no part of me that thinks that's
the optimal way
to
handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
no
um
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris jada had nothing to
do with it
i'm sorry babe
um
i'm gonna say sorry to my my kids and
and my family
for
the heat that i brought on
all of us
um to all my fellow nominees
you know this is a community it's like i
won because you you voted for me and it
really breaks my heart to have
stolen and and harnessed tarnished your
moment
um
i can still see
quest love's
eyes you know it it happened on quest
love's award and
you know
it's like i'm i'm
i'm sorry really is it
sufficient
what would you say to the people who
looked up to you
before the slap or people who expressed
that you let them down
um
so there's two things one
um
disappointing people is my central
trauma
i hate
when
i let people down
so
it
it hurts
uh it hurts me psychologically and
emotionally to know i didn't live up to
uh people's
image and impression of me
and
the work i'm trying to do is
i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself right i'm a
human
and
i made
a mistake
and
i'm trying not to think of myself as a
piece of um
so
i would say to those people i know
it was confusing i know it was shocking
um
but i i promise you
i am
uh deeply devoted and committed to
putting light and love and joy
into the world and
you know
if you if you hang on i promise we'll be
able to be friends again